[Musique]
des réflexions des interrogations depuis
les années 60 ben pose sur ses toiles
ses humeurs ses états d'âme ici à la
maison triolet aragon il part à la
recherche de la vérité où est passée la
vérité c'est le nom donné à cette
exposition présentée jusqu'au 27
novembre moi j'ai aimé l'idée d'exposer
déchets à elsa triolet aragon parce que
c'est pas une connotation intellectuelle
qui me servait à quelque chose ou pas
mais ça m'a plu et pied j'ai vu les
dépliants il ya eu mise à me monory
compagnie quand l'exposé ici donc je me
suis dit c'est un beau lieu mais savait
pas qu'il ya tellement demandé je ne
savais pas que c'était si important que
ça une recherche sur la vérité mais
aussi et toujours cette introspection
guise de fil conducteur l'égoïsme la
recherche du succès ben assume et
revendique ses contradictions c'est un
peu comme l'était un peu un peu quelque
chose moi c'est que un à douze candidats
on compte que il est toujours à la
recherche de la voirie et à la recherche
de lui même et elle recherche donc un
moment donné
ils s'aiment pas beaucoup mais il peut
pas faire autrement non plutôt qu'elles
avaient qu il ya des moments où on a des
piles de l'idée du mois qui ne pensent
qu'au mois plasticien ben est aussi un
performeur il aime interpellé son public
et n'hésite pas à improviser lors du
vernissage une conférence interactive
sur son travail il ya des passages dans
laquelle des gens bien prenez un bain de
champagne hawks et ben oui c'est beau
magnifique symbole cela et en fin de
compte que c'est une
exposition dans lequel on est pour ou
contre j'aime jal tact soutien des
banques qui est du doute
égocentrique mais qui aime être bousculé
dans ses certitudes ben est un artiste
provocateur et pour saisir les
subtilités de son oeuvre le musée
maillol à paris lui consacre en marge de
cette exposition une rétrospective
complète